I would love to know what every
character in my favorite video game
would look like in real life so what
does one do when they wonder about
something head to the internet I've got
some hilarious content where Kratos from
God of War looks like somebody's dad the
Pac-Man characters are giving stranger
things a run for their money and not
gonna lie AI didibuki from Street
Fighter incredibly dirty we have a full
eight games with our guy Kratos so it's
easy to say we have a clear vision of
what he would look like whether it's in
a video game or IRL but that isn't gonna
stop me from trying to get a real life
visual when I first scoured Reddit I
stumbled across this user-generated
version of him which not gonna lie looks
like my best friend from high school's
dad I continued my search on Twitter
where Dan Lowe the senior staff Tech
animator at Sony created a version of
Kratos using AI it's like he knew
exactly what I wanted to see he also
created a version of atreus because he
obviously knew where my Google searches
were gonna to go next overall I'm pretty
satisfied with the outcome of these
characters but what do you think of them
who else was madly addicted to Street
Fighter back in the day if you're
interested in what the AI came up with
for our girl jury there's a whole Reddit
Thread about it if you want to Deep dive
into that rabbit hole for now I've got
the SparkNotes version for you so for
some reason the AI turned her signature
eye patch into a pair of glasses and not
gonna lie made her look a little like
your overachieving science lab partner
naturally a lot of Street Fighter fans
weren't vibing with this AI creation
some even going as far to say that if
jury actually saw it she'd kick that AI
algorithm in the face I'm inclined to
believe them I told you guys I'm
obsessed with Street Fighter you know
I've gotta talk about ibupi next this
was a creation of a street fighter fan
on Twitter not sure how I feel about it
but it's definitely an entertaining
sight the reason why AI had a hard time
with this was because Ibuki always hides
her face with a mask as we've seen in a
lot during the covid pandemic though she
doesn't do it to protect herself from
the vid she uses the mask to hide her
identity so she can go to high school
like a normal girl and also kick serious
ass in every Martial Arts Tournament so
yeah we love and respect the mask but AI
did her a little dirty because of it
which Final Fantasy is your favorite I
love the remake of Final Fantasy VII so
had to give sephiroth a moment here the
Remake is absolutely stunning and if you
haven't played it I highly recommend
luckily for me IGN was also curious
about what sephiroth would look like IRL
so it didn't take a ton of dig in for me
to find some cool AI Renditions he's
given a little bit of The Lord of the
Rings elf but I'm not gonna lie I'm not
mad about it if you haven't seen all the
videos on this channel about Lord of the
Rings definitely check those out the
only thing that's not really giving in
this AI creation though is the hair it's
looking a little thin you know sephiroth
would have had a head full of flowing
locks Jack and Daxter first stepped onto
the sea seen in 2001 way before AI was
even considering generating video games
for us obviously because these
characters are much older than some of
the others really talking about the AI
versions are a little well interesting
the hair is probably my favorite part of
this rendition it's giving something
it's pretty cool though to see the AI
turn them into a strictly human version
of themselves AI can only do its job if
it can identify facial features to work
with so unfortunately we won't be
getting any real-life visuals of Sonic
the Hedgehog unless someone wants to go
ahead and create that for me let me know
no I'm not talking about Alicia vikander
or Angelina Jolie though I really really
could catch me on the next video anyway
I'm talking about the OG Lara Croft from
the 1996 video game Tomb Raider
obviously the AI doesn't do too well
with r90s video game icons but it didn't
stop me from looking into it anyway not
gonna lie though I was kind of impressed
with this rendition especially after
seeing how Jack and Dexter turned out
they got her bone structure pretty spot
on her eyes though changed a lot even
still I'm not too mad about this look
what do you guys think the smartest
ghost in all of Pac-Man I can't tell you
how many times he snuck around the
corner and got me on my last life I'll
tell you right now though if this was
what was chasing me all those years I
was playing I'd definitely still be
having some nightmares about it the
ghosts are definitely giving some sort
of alien sci-fi creature that came
straight out of the upside down I could
definitely see vechna mind controlling
these guys for sure so obviously the
ghosts are terrifying but what about
Pac-Man yeah equally terrifying petition
for someone to recreate the Pac-Man
games into this horroresque Survival
game hit me up in the comments and I'll
sign it anyway the fact that Pac-Man has
like 42 eyes is frightening enough but
those teeth look like they'd give sharks
a run for their money can you imagine
what sort of sound would be coming out
of him as he's tearing up those little
yellow orbs and ghosts as someone who's
really into horror I have proof alright
you know we have to talk about Mario not
the Chris Pratt version I've got in my
head after he voiced him but the AI
version which honestly is giving if
Mario actually looked like this I'd be
even more surprised that peach can't
give him the time of day he saved her
what over a hundred times he's had more
careers than I could possibly list here
come on girl what does it take speaking
of our girl let's see what the AI cooked
up for her again I see why Mario has
been obsessed with her for decades I'd
be down to save her from an evil castle
or to myself I wouldn't go as far as
Bowser did like I don't know slide into
her DMS or something before you go all
wild with the kidnapping scenario there
are definitely other ways to get
attention my guy also I can still see
this version of peach being voiced by
any Taylor Joy any day but what do you
guys think is there someone else you had
in mind for her this is another one that
took a bit of a turn down the road of
horror for those of you who haven't
played the game it's definitely one of
those that can turn a wholesome game
night with your friends into a
completely different vibe basically
there's a group of players running
around trying to do tasks but two people
in the group are actually trying to off
everyone before they can complete them
if you find a body you can call a
meeting to try and decipher who it is
but half the time your group chooses to
vote out the wrong person can you tell
him getting flashbacks anyway this
rendition is absolutely terrifying can
you imagine if the characters actually
looked like this it would be a whole lot
scarier trying to figure out who done it
an all-time childhood favorite obviously
we did get a Pikachu movie but it was
still giving more of a stuffed animal
Vibe though it was still nice to see our
favorite starter Pokemon on screen I'm a
huge Pokemon fan so obviously I would
take a real life Pikachu any day of the
week regardless of how many times I was
sent to the ER for being electrocuted in
this online creation Pikachu does seem
more along the lines of a household pet
and companion but I'd love to to see
those Powers Come to Life Link is often
mistaken for those who aren't familiar
with the video games anyway as Zelda
because he's the protagonist of the
series first launching back in 1996 with
the Legend of Zelda Link has had 19
different adventures in the series
throughout those Adventures he's been
depicted in tons of different ways many
times as multiple different ages but the
way he's looked has always been pretty
consistent he's typically depicted as
more or less human but with Elven
features like his wardrobe and the
pointed ears I think the AI was pretty
spot on with him but what do you think
come on you had to know Princess Zelda
would be my next train of thought over
here again for those who are less
familiar with the series Zelda is a
friend of Link whose role is often the
Damsel in Distress her character is very
popular among cosplayers and your
average Gamers even though her look has
shifted a lot throughout the years it
seems like the AI sort of took all of
her looks and smashed them all together
for this creation I'm not mad it though
were you surprised by how horrific and
like hilarious some of these video game
creations were obviously some were
majorly spot on but even with how
advanced AI technology is some things
like wearing a mask can really throw the
algorithm for a loop who are some of
your favorite video game characters
you'd like to see in real life